3 reasons why you may be deemed medically
inadmissible in Canada.
Number one, if you are a danger to public health.
Number 2. If you are a danger to public safety.
And lastly, if the immigration believes
that your medical condition will cause
excessive demand on Canadian health and social services,
they may deem you inadmissible.
And also remember that your medical
is only valid for 12 months.
So let's say you came here on a student visa
or a work permit.
You will again need to give your medical exam
when you apply for your permanent residency.
And then they will reassess this whole medical
inadmissibility thing
again based on the current medical results.